you could be like a criminal who goes on
the run you know you're hiding from the
fbi
you know go
when i was a kid
watching the guns like the guns or
movies from like new york and i was
like oh that's a good avenue for myself
i can i can be a great man
that's why i know my wife like me he's a
new guy every two months
and i can make her laugh so
yeah well that might be the funniest
thing anybody's ever said on this
podcast that's so funny oh look i
believe
look at the guy at the top right who is
that guy that's a viking that is a
viking
dangerous viking this guy on the top
left maybe is also maybe
business he might be a businessman or
like a rich grandson wealthy son of like
a man
yes yes yeah i see that the guy in the
middle on the left obviously is going to
prison yeah he he was caught with some
crack and some the guy on the right
in the middle now that guy is a
conquistador huh conquistador there you
go yeah dude this i'm surprised with
this picture i never saw this one and
the guy on the bottom is that you on the
bottom right yeah that was before they
all the fight below that was before
jesus christ bro that was a long time
ago
that looks like it's from like the
prehistoric times yeah i saw that the
water turned into wine yeah
i saw that
like you're from the jungle man that's
wild and dude i can tell you there's
like at least
six or seven myths in here oh totally
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one